I'm going to be living like Willy Wonka
for 24 hours and we're going to find out
if my homemade candy making skills are
better than Feasta bles that's right I'm
Coming For You Mr Beast to truly immerse
myself in Wonka's world I sought
guidance from some local candy experts
out in the wild let's see what they had
to
[Music]
say dirt
soda shoveled and bottled in the
USA what Incarnation the modes of
transportation in this town are whack
why are there no chocolate rivers that
get around town this sucks I got to
drive he you look sharp dude thank you
since the candy makers weren't there at
the first store I had to go and try a
different one this is my kind of
place I love you Willy won I love you
too yeah I
am me you have a good day
this is what we need to
do I'm trying to become a tro here
myself
[Music]
whatever then this random guy approached
while I was eating the cookie that I
ordered so are you a chocolate here or
what what do you what's your what's your
story I'm I think of myself as an
entrepreneur and someone who's just
trying to bring joy into people's lives
okay do you think I look good in purple
I think first of all I think it's Unique
when you walk into a chocolate place and
you see a
guy game like that you
got yeah I like that kind of I like
people that are having fun you guys have
a have time to put the candy Maker's
advice to the test I tried my hand at
being a greeter in the busiest candy
store in my town all while trying to not
blow my cover I don't know if they'll
get upset I'm I'm kind ofering welcome
guys
thank you you have a good day oh an
employee didn't walk
outome guys a lot of people probably
thought that I worked here
actually I'm not getting paid for
this oh oh sorry
I welcome in guys have a good day guys
really you're welcome hi guys welcome in
bil
walk
okay ized and in the true Spirit of
Willy Wonka it was time to whip up some
homemade chocolate and gummy bears let's
start
with Gummy Bears it needs a a thin layer
of oil Coating in each of
them that's our
son he not having it one second Willy
Wonka needs to get his son does Willy
Wonka even have a I don't think he has
kids but this one does can you imagine
if he had kids they be living a life the
chocolate River okay um dude I'm going
to need you to chill so I can start
cooking oh you got slobbered
[Music]
everywhere I got to make some I got to
make gummy bears I know it's
exciting oh that's that okay so we got
blue raspberry Starburst that actually
smells like Starburst that's pretty cool
we also got
[Music]
pink all right wait wo wo wo W stop
messing with my with my recipe here lady
I'm the I'm the candy maker I know how
to make
candy he's crying cuz it's a lie he's
not even crying he's screaming because
he's happy as I was saying I'm the candy
maker I'm experienced I've done this
hundreds of times I know exactly how to
make gummy
bears I
need can you go
get really
[Music]
sticky just
explode no we're good oh yeah it's
supposed to look exactly like
[Music]
that there we go you still have blue
left well I'll just drink it okay on to
chocolate is my OA Loompa not going to
help I was going to make my
brownies
I don't know how people made cooking
videos this is so much harder than I
thought it would
[Music]
be all right get that in there hold on
the plot Let It
Go the
anticipation that was really
[Music]
satisfying they're ready all right let's
press these bed boys up
cheers okay not bad it was time to put
our Homemade Creations to the ultimate
test a family taste off comparing our
candies to Mr Beast Feasta bles and
Haribo Gummy Bears the stakes were High
guys take your gummy bears these are the
store-bought ones let me know what you
[Music]
think they're pretty good
now for the homemade ones you are there
you are
[Music]
you like the homemade better all
right which one's
better got to go with the harell oh dang
it I'm going to say yours is better it's
not as
chewy it's good sweeter all
right I feel bad but I think I'm picking
the s you don't get to try the chocolate
then oh
no is it
good which one's
better that one yeah guy blue keep your
eyes open you can keep your eyes open
open your
eyes to
really yeah so my gummies had beat
Haribo but could my chocolate beat Mr
Beast here's febles Mr BEAST's chocolate
you try that my chocolate much better
chocolate mine better than mine's
better better than
febles homemade is better yeah all
right so that's homemade you just got
which one's better I really like the
homemade the homemade is better okay
[Music]
sweet I'm going to ball on that one dang
it that's fantastic not even close
homemade is better there you go that's
the
homemade store bought
wins I like yours mine's better yeah and
with that I had won according to my
completely unbiased family my Wonka
skills far surpass those of Mr Beast
living like Willy Wonka was definitely
an adventure though filled with laughter
fun and some Sweet Surprises but most
importantly it taught me that embracing
creativity and spreading Joy just like
Willy Wonka can truly sweeten life's
moments oh my God we got to cut the back
of this hat right here because right
now it does not go on my head so if we
want it to fit I'm just going to cut the
back and hopefully it'll be able to
slide down on the back of my
head you can't okay oh yeah baby hold on
let's see
back
h